مفاجاه السعوديه الاخيره امام الارجنتين
في كاس العالم وان كانت الابراج فهي ليست
الاولى في تاريخ المونديال سبقتها مفاجات
لكن ليست كثيره عاده المفاجات الا تحضر في
الحدث الكروي الابرز عالميا الا نادرا في
عام
1950 امريكا فاجات انجلترا بالفوز 1 - 0
انجلترا وصلت لمونديال البرازيل وهي واحده
من المرشحين لللقب وعرفت وقتها بمملكه كره
القدم لكن حضرت المفاجاه رغم ان مدرب
امريكا قال ليس لدينا فرصه ومن انجلترا
الى انجلترا لكن في عام
1960 الذي اقيم هناك لكن طرفي المفاجاه
كان مختلفين ايطاليا خسرت امام كوريا
الشماليه بهدف نظيف نحن الان في عام 1982
المونديال الذي اقيم في اسبانيا هذه مره
المفاجاه عربيه محاربوا الصحراء الجزائر
هزموا المانيا الغربيه بقائمتها النموذججه
بالنجوم بهد- بهدفين لهدف بعد ذلك ب 8
سنوات وفي مونديال ايطاليا 1990 كانت
الارجنتين ضحيه مفاجاه اخرى بطلها منتخب
الكاميرون الذي فاز على فريق مارادونا
بهدفا نظيف وفي عام 2002 مونديال كوريا
واليابان كانت دوله افريقيه اخرى هي بطله
المفاجاه لكن على حساب المنتخب الاوروبي
وليس امريكي جنوبيه السنغال وفي اول
مشاركه موندياليه لها حققت الفوز على بطله
العالم وقتها منتخب فرنسا